et la mise en oeuvre des sanctions
internationales vient de franchir une
étape importante les deux géants
mondiaux des cartes bancaires visa et
mastercard ont annoncé suspendre leurs
opérations en russie point parler nous
sommes en ligne avec m olivier dorgans
bonjour merci d'être avec nous vous êtes
spécialiste des sanctions
internationales visa et mastercard qui
suspendent leurs activités en russie
qu'est ce que cela peut avoir comme
impact pour les individus déjà et les
entreprises ensuite
alors c'est une blessure majeure qui
s'inscrivant dans la lignée des
sanctions qui ont été prises pour isoler
le système bancaire et du système
financier russe du reste du monde très
simplement visa et mastercard ont décidé
de choses elles sont d'une part décidé
que les cartes qui sont émises et
n'importe où dans le monde ne peuvent
plus être utilisées sur le territoire
russe et elles viennent également
d'interdire aux banques russes qui
émettent ces cartes de pouvoir les leurs
utilisateurs puissent les utiliser en
dehors de la russie donc ça vient
parachever cet isolement qui a commencé
depuis maintenant une dizaine de jours
très concrètement en termes de
conséquences pour pour les russes et
pour la population russe c'est une
incapacité par exemple d'honorer chat
qui tombait faire à l'étranger est l
inverse c'est une une incapacité pour
les ressortissants étrangers sur le
territoire russe de continuer à utiliser
des services de cette carte nous dit la
précision la carte les alesi chez moi
petite précision les cartes mastercard
et visa pourront continuer à être
utilisés sur le territoire russe par des
russes est exclusivement russie ce qui
compte ce qui me vient parachever cet
isolement et cette autarcie du système
bancaire russe quelles possibilités de
recours pour un particulier qui voit sa
carte désactiver
quasiment impossible 1 parce que dans
les conditions générales de ces de ces
deux grands géants des cartes bancaires
on est dans une prestation service qui
peut être dans des cas exceptionnels
comme c'est le cas aujourd'hui au titre
de la crise ukrainienne être être
suspendu donc donc les particuliers ne
pourront pas ne pourront pas faire de
recours encore une fois je le répète ce
qui est important c'est que ces cartes
continue de fonctionner sur le
territoire us pour les ressortissants
russes exclusivement et donc ça reste
encore une fois je pense que la
population même si c'est un univers
complémentaires ne verra pas
immédiatement les effets c'est plus par
rapport aux échanges entre la russie et
le reste du monde qu'on verra des effets
relativement relativement immédiatement
vladimir poutine dit que ça cinq scènes
internationales peuvent s'apparenter à
un acte de guerre il dit vrai ou c'est
de la rhétorique
c'était une forme de rhétorique mais là
où vladimir poutine effectivement sur
jusque-là vierge schelin au travers
cette rhétorique c'est le caractère
exceptionnel de ces sanctions ces
sanctions ont été adoptées contre la
russie sont inédites ce temps dans leur
forme que dans leur emploi vous donner
un exemple très concret la russie avait
par exemple la moitié des réserves très
importantes de devises et d'or ces
dernières années justement pour
éventuellement faire face à des
sanctions économiques comme celles qui
sont imposés contre actuellement contre
la russie et la ligne européenne a
décidé avec les alliés de priver la
banque centrale de russie de sa capacité
à utiliser ses réserves à l'étranger et
donc on va vraiment bien ce parallélisme
entre préparation de la russie et
actions prises par part par les alliés
par l'union par l'union européenne en
tête de file donc oui la lumière poutine
l'utilisent c'est cet élément qui est un
élément de rhétorique mais je pense que
dans cette rhétorique on doit également
voir le caractère exceptionnel et est
complètement inédit deuxième mesure en
termes de conséquences justement on a
cru comprendre que la russie s'était
préparé mais vu l'ampleur de ces
sanctions telles qu'elles ont été
déployés
est ce que cette préparation a été
suffisante
je pense que la russie a été très
clairement surprise le gouvernement de
l'alien petit n'était très clairement
surpris par surpris par l'unité et
l'ampleur des mesures qui ont été qui
ont été prises par les pays occidentaux
après le seul point qui permet à la
russie on le tient encore aujourd'hui de
ne boire pas son économie s'effondrer
chez les hydrocarbures les recettes du
de la russie sont principalement
structurée autour de la vente de la
production d'exploration et la vente
d'hydrocarbures et des cages et ses
ventes ce ne sont pour l'instant pas 5
indique d'ailleurs les banques qui ont
ont été progressivement déconnectés du
réseau swift ne sont pas des banques qui
sont utiles dans le financement de ses
opérations grèce presse banques et bear
banques restent des banques son qui sont
membres du réseau swift pour l'instant
et donc tant qu'on ne touche pas à cette
recette à ses réserves de pétrole et
cette capacité pour la gauche il
exploiter ses réserves pétrolières et
gazières la russie pour atelier à la
question c'est de savoir combien de
temps la russie pour rappel tenue merci
beaucoup m olivier dorgans avocat
spécialiste des sanctions
internationales
merci pour ces explications